the right to be forgotten is back on the
table in the libe committee MEP is
oppressed for businesses to uphold
European citizens data protection rights
American giant Google was at the center
of discussions the company utilizes
personal data for profiling and
marketing purposes will these rights
turn out in very severe sanctions if
they are infringed and that is very
important because we have very big
companies very big internet companies
who could just pay it out of their
actual portal money if they are
sanctioned today and that need to be
changed we need to have a strong
enforcement in Europe do you girls say
they have received 70,000 requests since
the 30th of May for the withdrawal of
European Internet user data the
employment committee has set its sights
firmly on tackling undeclared or falsely
declared work to stamp out the
phenomenon which in dangers both the
sustainability of public finances and
workers health the European Parliament
is looking to create an eu-wide platform
the goal to develop more effective tools
for workplace inspections and better
cooperation between member states cost
of the operation almost 2.5 million
euros
almost a quarter of all fish caught in
European waters are thrown back into the
sea search waste leads to overfishing
and heavy losses for fishermen in the
coming years the EU will place a gradual
ban on discarding fish yo por el mejor
de berault refectory novios no soap as
adept a a local a harem near a totally
teri prison motiva for you are a visa
issue problem la Empire le ponemos
unpaid adapt a non-free Portugal a
totally to defeat the den a donkey full
organ easy to suck em if he is welcomed
the European year of development 4 2015
1 into citizens is aware of the years
work in this area talks to finalize the
priorities and details of the year are
well advanced in the development
committee